[Music]
in once I'm gone news o submitted by
kisses from Albania
yeah celebrities have started to rewrite
their wills to include limitations on
their CGI renderings oh yeah like the
hologram stuff mm-hmm
I'm glad you popped in to get that
choice cuz I like the idea of c2funk
I know hologram form and Michael Jackson
I saw Michael Jackson is it weird that I
feel bad when I see that so I'm like
damn like they're still working but it's
photons in the air okay print said he
never wanted that to happen damn and
they still I know I saw I saw what's up
why do they do that
oh no the Devils doing he's like you
don't [ __ ] with that like you Luyden me
rest in peace they just want to get even
put her in his will done
there's nothing yeah a hologram they
made it like this this like projected
thing is that the end of certain good
yeah oh yeah yeah and then people were
hating on Justin Timberlake cuz they're
like y'all have beef like all of a
sudden now you're like all four prints
how they happy Justin imprints upbeat uh
well I think prints had like called out
like I think it kind of went back and
forth a little bit but you know how like
everyone likes to blow [ __ ] up ya know I
think when Justin was doing that tribute
people were just like giving him [ __ ]
like Chloe being hypocrite I like both
yeah so now they're saying celebrities
are writing in their will like what
their CGI renderings can can do or what
they can say or your type of projects
they can be involved in and so like I
can't even believe that this is on
people's minds now it's like we're so
future future yeah like a black mirror
episode we're there it's like now you
can have sex with your favorite
celebrity and then you know whoever owns
the rights for the CG of the celebrity
you could turn them into like a porn
star I don't like that VR reality
virtual reality [ __ ] [ __ ] them
because what if it's like black mirror
where your consciousness programmed
under there and then it's like if you
don't know the difference between you
being a CGI image and you being you
you have to [ __ ] all these people
because you're stupid other real self
sold the rights that's right today
people the estates of these celebrities
they're the ones making decisions on
what the CGI renderings can do yeah
and so now celebrities they want to take
that control into their own hands not
leave it up to the estate once they pass
so that's what they are setting certain
limitations but one of the examples that
they use is this chocolate this Dove
chocolate commercial that they used
Audrey Hepburn's nineteen year old self
so I'm gonna show you guys that
commercial and her son's approved of
this
Duff makes chocolate bar something it's
all good like they did such a great they
did what a gap did one with Audrey
Hepburn to like 15 years ago she was hot
yeah for the they're like black skinny
leg jeans maybe was 10 years ago but oh
yeah I remember that one it was a cool
campaign when I was younger I would
watch all these old people [ __ ] and I'm
like you still look old you nasty [ __ ]
and then lately I've been looking at
them like oh you're actually very young
now you're the old one and 2014
it's 2014 yeah
that's like Europe see Jean her yeah
it's not really her well it's her a
muted yeah did they use a body double
they did she just have like a green bag
over her that's dangerous girl you gonna
[ __ ] step into a car what a [ __ ]
stranger like that back then guys my
creepy dude they used to rape women I
know I'm kidding she said in the back
there you go home girl where you belong
yes ought to be chauffeured exactly oh
hell yeah dark chocolate that [ __ ]
dark a stop Castley I don't want my
factory making my soap and chocolates at
the same time you know she's one of
those people with that those Hollywood
stories where some director was just on
the beach and he was or she was like
this and she he was like oh I found my
yeah yeah that's how she got her first
kid you know I've seen that [ __ ] in that
I found my Gigi
so my I she was a fashion designer and
so as a kid I would follow her around
and stuff and she worked at like this
company and Tokyo I forgot I was called
and we're just walking around Taiwan and
she'll see someone's like crazy like
bone structure you should like I need
your phone number right now and I'm just
like what the hell's going on you know
like she'll get that person's phone room
anytime I see that happen in real life
it's either a scam or yeah scalp report
to me it was like some dude on the
street like hey you got an agent I'm an
agent actually here's my email address
it's hot guy 101 Kol da
I'm more like you got a demo reel cuz I
need that in order to market you if it's
not a fat Jewish guy with a huge cigar
and [ __ ] circle glasses and he talks
like Nessie like I I'm not gonna be like
hey see I'm gonna make you a star see
we're gonna be rich and famous this is
how you think juice no no like Hollywood
producer Jews yeah like hey see I'm
gonna make you a star see is that how
Weinstein talks no but the guys that
that scout you talk like that
specifically guys that are just like
waiting to make you a star they all like
are short with like cigars and famous
yeah they have a fat cigar they're all
like Danny DeVito yeah yeah and they
have like a strong fear like that yeah
you said his name and I was like Al
Pacino no it's Robert De Niro in a
Scorsese movie let's do it is Al Pacino
like good looking good Robert De Niro or
Al Pacino right now though I don't know
I like I like Al Pacino's character cuz
he's like that [ __ ] man man like I
might be small but I'm [ __ ] huge
what if they play the same character cuz
they were actually auditioned for the
same role
yeah but DeNiro he makes me nervous cuz
he doesn't talk very much you like I
like that kind of looks at you like this
- nerd what are you looking at
oh the Darrell cuz both dinero's
actually really skinny he's like a tall
skinny guy and then she keep kind of
like got big they're both pretty
good-looking though yeah yeah they got
really good genes we're gonna have lunch
love you could talk cause a little 90
mark he looks like you could yeah he
doesn't look like a criminal yeah maybe
I changed my mind
he's got a swab element about that and I
[ __ ] up and I said I'm gonna go out
right
yeah I go al pacino my guys like kind of
looks like Robert Downey jr. oh yeah you
know that looks like Al Pacino to me is
Oscar Isaac the guy that plays a PO
whatever in nesstar wars like a slightly
all up more olives yeah more Hispanic
Latino tallien but you know I could you
know sounds abelian for sure cuz you
played a color victimized or Cuban you
played a Cuban these Italian yeah is
that brown face a brown guy playing a
brown guy what happened invisible
trumpet over there
round people don't seem to get offended
by Asians do Asians yeah fitness like
hardcore right it's like if your
Colombian playing a Mexican roll or like
a Spaniard playing uh like a Cuban like
no one gets like there hell yeah you
know how much flag [ __ ] Jennifer Lopez
got from playing Selena she got a
[ __ ] why how come it's not as
loud
it was huge dude yeah was it was huge do
you remember that I don't remember that
no cuz there's no fishy order II I just
never heard anyone getting we're pissed
that Jennifer Lopez
cuz Al Pacino's Italian and he played
Scarface yeah maybe it's forgiving cuz
he's a good actor maybe like their [ __ ]
we just don't know enough of the best
yeah yes I thought he was Italian in
Scarface with these a Cuban I saw when I
was like young okay that's like 12 but
real quick though I'm glad you showed
the Audrey Hepburn thinkers and then we
started talking about Al Pacino and
Martin Scorsese because I'm just I just
want to plug the Irishman
cuz it's a new movie directed by Mark
Scorsese are you getting a brandy no did
you walk he loves movies no they just
finished they rat they've just read
Marcis new movie it's an Al Pacino
Robert De Niro and Joe Pesci spending
so we had young Pacino young De Niro eg
and then they grow old into their modern
and their current age it's [ __ ] like
I'm [ __ ] ready for that movie when is
it coming up I don't know and they just
wrapped and they had to drill out of CG
so probably another year - oh my god
sounds amazing
the Irishman and it's three Italians
playing Irish people yes like the og
Italian actors Pacino we've always
wanted them in the same movie but wait
how are they young CG honey w watch the
Audrey Hepburn thing I'll say what the
[ __ ] and then we start talking about
that oh wait are they still voicing
their younger selves
I hope so and then they're gonna alter
the voice you know they did that with
Johnny Depp on the Pirates of the
Caribbean movie the latest one Caribbean
a cruise don't know I know I never know
Gio I feel like it's caramel caramel ha
what is adjectives I do Caribbean and
then when it's at the end as a noun I do
Caribbean like Caribbean cruise yeah
describing the cruise Caribbean good
safe Caribbean pirates of the Caribbean
treasures in the Caribbean but they did
tornadoes in the Caribbean they didn't
hire a younger actor for when they did
the flashback they just made his face
much page of French CGI bit oh how they
did Brad Pitt and Benjamin Button as
dough
[Music]